Lara Sanders and Sam Makonnen went  straight from their wedding to a protest  in LA and I got to speak to the  newlyweds enjoy what was that moment  like that when you get out of the car  you have your Chuck's on she has her  dress we're in this white car with  flowers and we're driving through the  chaos oh it's like a movie the enemy he  said Larry would you change the world  you will like next to it let me print my  name it was shaking we wanted to get  involved and and stand in solidarity how  did you end up having this zoom wedding  I think there's 500 people I 15  countries and four continent and all the  celebrity friends because we  entertainment business had been there  and Hosmer didn't he give a toast seems  to be the wedding of the century I think  we wanted to just represent like  represent hope in all of this bad news  that's going on and also love conquers  all  [Music]